EXASPERATED VOICES ASKING WHY
ISN'T THE MEDIA FOCUSING ON ALL
GOOD NEWS.
THINK ABOUT THAT.
AS CAPITALISM ROARS ON, ONE OF
OUR MAJOR NEWS OUTLETS DUBBED
THE SOVIET UNION'S ECONOMIC PLAN
THE ADOLESCENT MIND-SET IN
TODAY'S MEDIA AND HOLLYWOOD.
WHAT A PERFECT SNAPSHOT OF THE
LEFT.
THE MOST DISCREDITED ECONOMIC
SYSTEM EVER -- LOOK AT
VENEZUELA.
TO CNN'S CHILDREN THAT DOESN'T
MATTER.
IT'S ALL ABOUT BEING COOL.
THE DOW'S WARS 401(K)s GROW,
THEY LAUD A SYSTEM THAT RUINED
MILLIONS OF LIVES.
WHY ARE WE MINCING WORDS?
IT'S NOT CNN.
CHECK OUT THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
WHICH HAS ALL BUT PURGED ITS
MODERATES NOW LEAVING THE PARTY
TO BERNIE-LOVING PROGRESSIVES.
THAT'S WHAT WE SHOULD BE CALLING
THEM ROUTINELY.
AS LONG AS THE ECONOMY IS DOING
GREAT, THE MEDIA IS NOT GOING TO
LISTEN BECAUSE TO THEM
CAPITALISM IS JUST AN ILLUSION
AND AN UNCLE ONE.
IT'S NOT LIKE SOCIALISM, A
DREAMY, FLUFFY IDEOLOGY
DECIMATING VENEZUELA AND CUBA AS
IT'S MISERY IS COLOR-BLIND.
ONLY THE MEDIA CAN'T SEE IT.
THAT WAS A REALLY STUPID TWEET,
DANA.
>> Dana: I THINK SO TOO.
FROM A COMMUNICATION STANDPOINT,
BEFORE THE FINANCIAL CRISIS OF
2008, THE BUSH ADMINISTRATION
HAD A SIMILAR PROBLEM.
WHY WON'T THE MEDIA COVER THE
GOOD NEWS IN THE ECONOMY, THE
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE WAS LOW.
I FELT IN SEPTEMBER 2008 IT ALL
CHANGED.
THE WHITE HOUSE NEEDS TO MAKE A
CHOICE.
THEY COULD WIN BY COMPLAINING OR
THEY COULD SHOW, NOT TELL MAKE
THE MEDIA COVERED IT.
MEDIA HAS TO COVER IT.
MAKE THEM FOLLOW HIM WHEREVER HE
GOES.
ALL OF THOSE.
>> Greg: THE WALL STREET
JOURNAL ASKED 68 ECONOMISTS
WHERE DID THEY LEARN THAT FROM?
"WALL STREET JOURNAL."
THAT'S US.
FAIR REPORTING AND ACCURACY.
AND THEY SHOULD GIVE CREDIT
WHERE CREDIT IS DUE.
I WAS APPLAUDING THEM.
WHILE I WAS READING TO SAY OKAY,
THIS MAKES SENSE.
THINGS ARE GOING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION.
WILL THEY CONTINUE TO BE
FORTHRIGHT, THE MEDIA AND THE
REST OF THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA TO
GIVE PRESIDENT TRUMP THE CREDIT
FOR HIS ECONOMIC GAINS THAT HE'S
BEEN ABLE TO OBTAIN EARLY IN HIS
PRESIDENCY.
>> Greg: WE CAN'T JUST BLAME
THE MEDIA ENTIRELY.
THINGS ARE GOING GREAT, WHICH IS
GOOD NEWS.
BUT TRUMP OFTEN -- HE CAN STEP
ON IT BY DO SOMETHING IN THE
>> Jesse: I GUARANTEE YOU HE'S
GOING TO STEP ON THE GOOD NEWS.
DANA MADE A GREAT SUGGESTION.
I REMEMBER WHEN PRESIDENT OBAMA
WOULD DO THESE TOURS.
THE 99%.
PRESIDENT TRUMP SHE DO THE SAME
THING AND GO TO THESE PLACES,
ESPECIALLY MANUFACTURING TOWNS
AND TOWNS IN WISCONSIN
PENNSYLVANIA AND OHIO.
>> Dana: HE IS GOING THURSDAY.
>> Jesse: TALK ABOUT
CAPITALISM AND RIPPING APART
REGULATIONS.
COCKTAIL BECAUSE IT LOOKED GREAT
COCKTAIL BECAUSE IT LOOKED GREA
INCREDIBLE PERFORMANCE.
YOU HAVE TO GIVE THE PRESIDENT A
LITTLE BIT OF CREDIT FOR IT.
DRIVEN BY CONSUMER CONFIDENCE.
HE IS RIPPING UP REGULATIONS,
THE TAX CUTS ARE HELPFUL AS
WELL.
THOUSAND DOLLAR BONUSES TO
MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF
WORKERS.
THOSE BIG CORPORATIONS WERE
SUPPOSED TO SHOWER THE
EXECUTIVES WITH BIG BONUSES.
WORKERS GOT BONUSES TOO.
AT THE END OF THE OBAMA
PRESIDENCY WE LOST 19,000
MANUFACTURING JOBS.
THOSE WERE THE TYPES OF JOBS
AMERICANS WANT TO SEE COME BACK
AS LONG AS WE GET THE WAGES TO
KEEP GROWING AT A STRONGER PACE
THAN THEY ALREADY ARE.
I DON'T SEE HOW HE LOSES
REELECTION.
>> Greg: JUAN, YOU ALWAYS TALK
ABOUT HOW CRAZY THIS TABLE IS.
YOU KNOW 90% OF THE MEDIA
COVERAGE IS NEGATIVE.
COULD IT BE BECAUSE THEY SEE
GOOD NEWS IS BAD NEWS?
BASIC CAPITALISM DOING SO WELL,
THEY GO WELL, IT'S NOT BECAUSE
IT'S CAPITALISM.
LIKE THE CNN TWEET EXPOSES THEM
FOR BEING MORE FAVORED TOWARDS
SOCIALISM.
GOOD NEWS TO THEM IS ALWAYS BAD
AND WHY YOU SEE OUR TABLE AS
CRAZY.
>> Juan: I THINK HE SHOULD GO
ON A TOUR.
HE SHOULD GO TO MAR-A-LAGO AND
NEW JERSEY AND WALL STREET WITH
HIS BUDDIES.
HE COULD CAMPAIGN WITH THE 1%.
THEY COULD ALL SAY
MR. PRESIDENT, YOU ARE DOING
GREAT FOR US.
FORGET THOSE LITTLE PEOPLE.
>> Jesse: WALL STREET DIDN'T
DO WELL UNDER PRESIDENT OBAMA?
>> Juan: HATED FINE.
HAVE A MINUTE AGO YOU WERE
MAKING THE CASE --
IN AN EXTENDED RECOVERY.
ASK THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
WHO GETS CREDIT?
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, 49-40 GIVE
CREDIT TO OBAMA, NOT TRUMP.
>> Jesse: NEXT YEAR AS IT
CONTINUES TO GROW.
>> Juan: LET'S HOPE.
IT >> Greg: AMAZING HE GETS
PRESS AND A LOT OF PEOPLE DON'T
LIKE HIM.
A LOT OF PEOPLE WANT TO GIVE
THEIR BOSS CREDIT BECAUSE THEY
DON'T LIKE THE BOSS BUT THE BOSS
IS DOING PRETTY GOOD.
I AM SAYING A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE
ACCURATELY SAYING OVER THE LONG
RUN, LOOK AT WHERE THIS
PROSPERITY COMES FROM.
WITH REGARD TO THE SOCIAL
ECONOMICS, I THINK SOCIALISM IS
A CORRUPT SYSTEM.
I THINK YOU BASICALLY PUT
GOVERNMENT IN CHARGE OF YOUR
LIFE.
IT'S NOT COMMUNISM, THOUGH,
LET'S BE CLEAR ABOUT THAT.
THAT'S THE SOVIET SYSTEM.
>> Greg: WHY SPLIT HAIRS?
>> Juan: WHEN YOU HEAR SOMEONE
LIKE KING TALK ABOUT THE
NEGATIVE EFFECTS OF CAPITALISM
COMMONLY THINK YOU DO NEED
BRAKES ON CAPITALISM SO DOESN'T
RESULT IN TREMENDOUS INCOME
INEQUALITY, FULL IN THE STREETS.
>> Greg: PEOPLE IN THE STREETS
STREETS IN NEW YORK.
WE NEED ECONOMIC --
>> Greg: I KNOW, UNDER
DE BLASIO.
THE LIBERAL MAYOR.
JUAN, QUIT WHILE YOU ARE AHEAD.
>> Juan: ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY
IN THIS COUNTRY AND HAVE TO WORK
TOWARD IT.
BY THE WAY, BEFORE YOU GO, DO
THINK HE HELPS HIMSELF WITH THE
MEDIA WHEN HE SAYS OH, WHAT
ABOUT OBAMA WIRETAPPING AND WHAT
FAKE NEWS AWARD.
DO YOU THINK THIS HELPS?